bien avant que ça devienne une musique
de soirée retour aux origines de la
musique électro au tout début c'était
une histoire d'onde
voici les ondes theremin créée en 1918
en 1919 ça se passe sur clavier avec les
ondes martenot créé par maurice martenot
[Musique]
on
la musique devient électronique car elle
suit son temps c'est ce qu'explique le
compositeur très moderne jacques lasry
vous savez que les compositeurs font de
la musique avec le bruit de fond de la
vie dans laquelle il existe ainsi à
l'époque de mozart c'était quand même le
savon d'une valve la diligence la
respiration le coeur humain et ses
rythmes simples et enfin caractéristique
de l'époque
maintenant nous sommes je crois à
l'époque du métal avec l'électronique
les sons peuvent être enregistrées
reproduit modifié synthétiser bien avant
le synthétiseur déjà dans les années 40
avec l'audio line
[Musique]
la musique électronique a même tenté une
percée dans le sacré avec l'orgue
électronique lire au début c'était pour
l'église et puis elles étaient réticents
alors les variétés s'en sont emparés et
le jazz savez comme moi maintenant on ne
conçoit plus le jazz sang et or dans les
années 60 des jeunes compositeurs
s'approprient ces nouveaux sons voici
walter carlos 20 ans compositeur
étudiants en musique et en physique qui
a interprété bac au synthétiseur
[Musique]
l'un des premiers à faire carrière dans
la musique électro désormais un courant
à part entière
[Musique]